c'est drôle parce quelqu'un on a
commencé il ya cinq ans c'est presque
une utopie jugeant le voyait comme un
modèle assez spécial mais non dans
longtemps parlé partout l'économie
circulaire est devenu un mot que
monsieur madame tout le monde veut
connaître alors n'hésitez pas le cas
quand on a commencé sauf qu'un super
bonne à l'intérieur mais il est
constamment apparu on aime 104,9 yens
entraînées par faire c'était partir de
fruits et légumes invendus que lou
fabrique toute sa gamme de jus frais ils
ont été précurseurs dans ce nouveau
modèle économique anti gaspillage non en
fait j'ai eu avec ça même qui attentent
un petit peu plus mûr comme ça il ya
encore plus de jus
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on boit on
pressent et fruits légumes on extrait le
jus mais toute cette fait bloc est
encore très bonne pour la consommation
on voulait la réutiliser aussi donc on
explorait plusieurs plusieurs avenues
pour le faire puis on entre autres
développer un super beau partenariat
avec tree sic pour nourrir leurs
insectes à partir de cette tel plan si
on a de la pub de carhaix donc c'est le
résidu du pressage de jus qui fait chez
jules houcke nous on va chercher les
résidus de la transformation alimentaire
chez différents producteurs par exemple
et jules houcke la boulangerie genres et
les microbrasseries et on ramène les
produits si vers nos installations avec
danton l'utiliser pour nourrir la telle
vache d'un sexe et des ténébrions on a
environ 60 millions d'un siècle
[Musique]
le 2 mai
quelle quantité de sang vous venez
chercher aujourd'hui 200 kg de son
public s'élevant à ce qu'on collecte à
chaque semaine
puis on fait quoi l'huile est son y
avait vraiment pour moi une volonté de
points gaspillés c'est quand même une
matière première dont je voulais pas le
jeter que alexis plus utilisée après
pour sa production de ténébrions ces
faits comme c'est merveilleux ya aucune
perte
à quelques pas de la boulangerie alexis
récupère les résidus de brassage de
bière connaissent la drêche des
microbrasseries voile récolter le
déshydraté le maître en farine pour
pouvoir le donner aux insectes c'est
presque zéro déchet comme un production
parce que les insectes vont consommer
les aliments et toutes les insectes par
la suite seront récoltés pour
l'alimentation
l'économie circulaire en alimentation
n'est pas qu'une affaire urbaine la
preuve ça circule aussi beaucoup dans le
sous sol d'un tome en protéines à
cap-santé près de québec les gens et non
c'est impossible ça se fait produits de
chips à la barre d'un sec j'ai persévéré
je continuais
marco poulin un beauceron type et
visionnaire s'est associé au chef daniel
vézina pour créer des chip à base de
dénis brio
daniel vézina pourquoi vous vous êtes
lancé dans une aventure de chet de
ténébrions fait samassa mois est appelé
tout de suite le quand j'ai vu la
quantité de protéines qu'on pouvait
produire dans un très petit espace dans
ta des bagues sont superposées peut
produire des kilos et des kilos de
protéines complètement au boeuf marcoux
élèves ces milliers d'insectes nourris à
partir de 3 à 4 tonnes de fruits et
légumes offerts gratuitement par métro
iga et cosco chaque année donc les deux
dames et circulaires en a il faut
légumes des extraits on a nos insectes
ici comme en poudre qui ont fait de
l'agroalimentaire puis la déjection d un
excellent regrette que rien n'est perdu
on récupère la chaleur des machines pour
chauffer en beau mais en même temps ça
prend plein c'est l' empreinte
énergétique est vraiment minime au moins
je l'espère alimentera c'est quelque
chose qui me tient beaucoup à coeur donc
je trouve que avec les ténébrions
gaspillage et en os pour les poubelles
ici rien dans les poubelles j'ai
travaillé pendant trois jours d'autant
plus on sent poli poubelle ou aux dames
hier on jette rien
[Musique]
surtout tout le maître ne reçoit plus je
faisais cheikh lô et c'est sûr que le
bonhomme est quand même assez drôle puis
et j'anticipe j'ai envie de travailler
que déjà aussi comme ceux auxquels on
donc on va faire la pâte on va faire ça
luca cao cao
et c'est de cette joyeuse association
que son équipe plutôt particulière
quand il m'a approché marco il voulait
avoir support ketchup sel poivre d'aig
moi je me dis est tellement un produit
quand même spécial quand même un produit
que les gens connaissent pas tant que ça
c'est un produit d'exception donc
pourquoi pour le mélanger avec d'autres
d'exception tchipa larmes aux yeux à la
lime ou qu'il savoure et facile au début
parce que carey ont goûté les premières
fois
il y a même des chip à la poudre de
champignons chagall mais c'est complexe
comme goulon ne pas juste une savane est
vraiment plein le coeur sens à la fin
les jeunes sont très attirées par ces
produits le plus compense une génération
le de foodies suivent les blogs puis ils
sont au courant de tout ces petits
produits là il fallu en faire beaucoup
avant qu'on ait vraiment le goût
escompté au public si les protéines de
ténébrions la balade dans l'op lire des
scénarios qu un arrière goût de
ténébrions l'ananas en tant qu on a une
meilleure déshydrateur au monde avec
cette machine on peut tout déshydraté
là-dedans nos produits à aller chercher
maman qu'elle tait le quel on le fait on
achète tout quelque peu après son
entorse d'un cp apprécions le rôle mais
en fait rien nous autres c'est tout
affecté
les fermes du site du québec l'alfa ça
va être là dessus parce qu'on fait là
cela chips pour des microbrasseries
c'est une première mondiale ça n'existe
pas nulle part il ya beaucoup de choses
à développer des microbrasseries bon
coin on peut utiliser la bière donc on
va c'est travailler pour garder
l'économie circulait à son maximum on va
aller chercher toutes les produits
locaux autour de 10
l'enjeu maintenant pour ces entreprises
est de trouver des emballages et zéro
déchet pour boucler la boucle parfaite
de l'économie circulait
[Musique]